-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
What a show tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is the show
to be at tonight.
Oh, my gosh.
Well, guys,
here's some big news.
According to a new study,
dogs are more effective
at detecting COVID
than rapid tests.
[ Laughter ]
I'm glad we reached the point in
the pandemic where the CDC is
like, "I don't know, dogs?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, knowing the CDC, in two
days, they're going to be like,
"Never mind, it's actually
rabbits. I'm sorry."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, I have no idea
what's going on.
Today, I saw Sarah McLachlan
snuggling a person
with COVID, asking pets to help.
I didn't know
what was happening.
[ Laughter ]
But here's how
it works with dogs.
If you have symptoms,
they sniff your crotch.
One hump --
[ Laughter ]
One hump means you're negative.
Two humps means you're positive.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's what they're saying.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Apparently, dogs are
better at detecting COVID
than rapid tests, which explains
now when you take
an at-home test,
the instructions look
a little different.
Yeah, now the steps are
one, open package.
Two, remove at-home COVID test.
Three, walk and feed
at-home COVID test.
[ Laughter ]
Four, receive unconditional love
from at-home COVID test.
Five, neuter at-home COVID test.
[ Laughter ]
Six, let at-home COVID test
sleep in your bed.
Move to couch.
That is your bed now.
[ Laughter ]
Seven, socialize with other
at-home COVID tests
at the at-home COVID test park.
Make small talk with other
at-home COVID test owners.
Eight, repeat step 7
for 16 years.
[ Laughter ]
Nine, tell kids
at-home COVID test
went to live on a farm upstate.
[ Laughter ]
Ten, try to get new
at-home COVID test.
Eleven, discover your wife
is allergic.
Twelve, get cat.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's the instructions.
[ Applause ]
-That's a lot.
-Some more news, I saw that gas
prices across the country have
once again surged
to a record high.
You know, at this point,
it's worth filling your car
with Mountain Dew and just
seeing what happens.
I mean, why not?
[ Laughter ]
What's the worst
that could happen?
I'm worried there's no solution
in sight.
Today, President Biden was like,
"Let's see if the COVID dogs
got anything on this."
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, today was
the busiest election day
before November with primaries
in many states,
including New Jersey,
California, and Iowa.
And there are a lot of races
and a lot of candidates.
So we thought we'd get you
caught up on what
the biggest issues are to some
of the candidates right now.
First there's Donald Payne Jr.
of New Jersey.
He's running on "making it legal
to dress like
a ventriloquist dummy."
[ Laughter ]
That's -- How is that --
How is that an issue?
-I didn't know it was illegal.
-These are issues they are
very concerned about.
Here's Dusty Johnson
of South Dakota.
He's running on
"changing his name to not
sound like he's
a '70s porn star."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, that's his issue?
-Dusty -- Dusty Johnson.
-Dusty Johnson.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a terrible name.
-Yeah, awful name.
He's got a dusty johnson.
[ Laughter ]
-Then there's Mike Crispi
from New Jersey.
-He's running on "joining the
rebooted cast of 'Jersey Shore'
as their gym tan lawyer."
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
"Your Honor."
-"Tan."
-"Your Honor." Yeah.
Finally, there's Rick Caruso of
California.
Higgins,
guess what he's running on.
-What?
-He's running on "getting people
to stop saying he looks like the
villain in a '90s Disney movie
where a monkey
takes over his hotel."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Get that chimpanzee out of
the laundry room!"
-"There is nothing
in the rule book."
-Some business news --
I read that Apple is rolling out
their own "buy now, pay later"
service called Apple Pay Later.
Trust me, you don't want to owe
money to a company that knows
your location and everything
you've ever
searched for online.
[ Laughter ]
And if you miss a payment,
they send over two skinny goons
from the Genius Bar named
Ethan and Zack.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Guys, listen to this. Tom Brady
just announced that he is
launching his own line of Brady
brand underwear.
Yep, it's the only underwear
that somehow looks better
after 22 years.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Bill Belichick is
asking Tom
for some underwear or outerwear.
[ Laughter ]
He'll take either one.
Get this. I saw that for the
summer, Panera -- I love Panera.
Panera is adding lobster mac
and cheese to their menu.
[ Audience oohs ]
Yeah, it's actually part of
Panera's broader strategy
to revamp their brand,
and it really seems like
they're making some big changes.
Watch this commercial I saw.
-Introducing the all-new
Panera Bread.
You've always loved our
sandwiches and delicious soups
served in bread bowls.
Well, now, come and try
our lobster mac and cheese.
Also served in a bread bowl.
Or cool off with our refreshing
lemonade, served in bread cups.
Hey, how about a bread salad
or a bread cookie
dunked in an ice-cold
glass of bread?
Enjoy it while you sit in
our bread booth.
And wave to our [Demonic voice]
bread employees
with your bread wife
and your bread kids
and your bread dog --
-[ Barks ]
-[ Normal voice ]
And we've got fresh bagels.
Panera Bread.
[ Demonic voice ] Bread!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Interesting.
-Wow!
-I heard that a -- I heard that
a massive lettuce shortage
in Australia has forced the KFC
restaurants there to put
cabbage on their burgers.
[ Audience groans ]
Yeah.
My question is, "Who's getting
burgers at KFC?"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
Oh, switch 'em up!
Switch 'em up!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Damn!
-They said the bad news is
"we're out of lettuce."
And then the customer said,
"Okay, then what's
the bad news?"
[ Laughter ]
-Hey!